لجنه التحقيق في احداث الكابيتول تتهم
ترامب بالانخراط بمؤامره لقلب نتيجه
انتخابات الرئاسه
روسيا تدعو الولايات المتحده الى الاسراء
بصوت العقل وتجنب اصطدام المباشر بين
البلدين
والازهري يدعو طالبان حرمان الفتيات من
التعليم
بدفع ثمن
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
بعد ثمانيه عشره شهرا من التحقيق اصدرت
لجنه مجلس النواب الامريكي لتحقيق في
احداث الكونجرس اصدرت تقرير عن النهائي
التقرير الذي يقع في 845 صفحه خلص الى ان
الرئيس السابق لم يمنع عن ساره
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2020
معنى لا مشاهدينا من واشنطن دكتور وليد
فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه اهلا بك دكتور معانا بدايه
دكتور ماذا يعني هذا التقرير ونتائج التي
خلصت اليه في ما يتعلق بالرئيس ترامب ما
الذي سيحدث الان
[موسيقى]
منتظرا جدا وليس كان هنالك انتظار لما
يمكن ان يحصل لانه منذ اليوم الاول لتاليف
تلك الاجماع وكل جلسات الاستماع التي حصلت
على مده سنه سنه ونص ربما اكثر كانت تدل
انه هذه الاكثريه وفيها فقد من الطرف الذي
يعرض الرئيس انها ستنتهي الى يعني الى
مبادئ او الى استنتاجات كما سمعنا لم نكن
نعرف التفاصيل ولكن وهذا الاهم هذه توصيات
لوزاره العدل يعني نحن نعرف جميعا عن
البرلمانات والكونجرس غير قادرين على ان
ينفذوا توصياتهم او مقرراتهم ترسل الى
وزاره العدل وهنالك على وزير العدل ان
يقرر اذا ان يقوم بملاحقات بناء على هذا
التقرير او لا هذا هو الوضع حاليا
الان با ده الموضوع خطوه الى الامام ام
انه يعني سينتهي هنا
الاحتمالان موجوده احتمال ان ياخذوا
الموضوع الى التحقيق لانه وزاره العدل
ستقوم بتحقيق مبني على هذا التقرير ولكن
عندها معطيات اكثر وتفاصيل اكثر واذا
توصلت الى نتائج انه في مسؤوليه عندها سوف
تعين تعين يعني همم فريق عمل بالنسبه لها
من ال- اا من المحامين العالمين
وليست اليه بين ليله وضحاها
هنالك احتمال اخر انه مع هذا الكونجرس
الجديد الذي فيه اكثريه من الجمهوريين لن
يكون الموضوع سهل لانه بامكان هذه
الاكثريه ايضا ان تعطل عمل وزاره العدل او
عن ان تخفف من وطئتها اذا القرار بتقديري
انا سوف يكون سياسي اكثر منه
قرار سياسي ماذا يعني بالنسبه
الرئيس ترامب الترشح مره اخرى في انتخابات
2024 على الاقل من الناحيه المعنويه من
ناحيه دعم همم يعني القاعده الجماهيريه له
بعد على الاقل توصيات الكوم ريس حتى وان
لم تصل الامور الى همم يعني المحاكم
الامريكيه
عندك نقاط النقطه الاولى ان الهدف الاساسي
هو شال القدره الرئيس او اضعاف قدره
الرئيس السابق بان يترشح بان ياخذ
الاجراءات الاداريه الاما هناك هذا الهدف
الاساسي وقد وصلوا الى القاعده التي سوف
تسمح بذلك ولكن النقطه الثانيه التي يجب
ان ننتبه اليها ان هذه اللجنه في هذا
الكونغرس تنتهي مهامها بعد بعد بضعه ايام
وياتي كونجرس جديد وما يمكن للكوميكس
الجديد تحت القوانين والدكتور الامريكي ان
يشكل لجنه اخرى وهذه اللجنه اخطر
تقوم بالتحقيق عن جديد وقد تصل لانه
اكثريتها من الجمهوريين الى همم يعني الى
نتائج مختلفه فيكون هنالك اصطدام بين
لجنتين لجنه ماضيه ولجنه اتيه امام وزاره
العدل مما قد يعرق العمل وزاره العمل يعني
الامور القانونيه والاداريه والاجرهريه هي
معقده بشكل لا اعتقد انه هذا اللي حدثته
سوف
يستعمل كسلاح ما يمكن ان يستعمل هو الامور
الاخرى الملفات الاخرى ان وجود وثائق
معينه في بيت او قصر الرئيس هذه عندها قدر
اكثر ان تتحرك من من هذه النتائج السياسيه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن دكتور وليد
فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه
قال مدير دائره امريكا الشماليه بالخارجيه
الروسيه
بصوت العقل والا تدفع بالامور نحو صدام
مباشر بين روسيا والولايات المتحده ودعم
اداره
شيف الولايات المتحده باطلاق ما وصفات
تدمير العلاقه الثنائيه مع روسيا واضاف
بان موسكو لا تعتزم العلاقات بمبادره منها
مؤكدا بان روسيا لن تتسامح مع الاستفزازات
المتعمده التي لا تترك لها خيارا
قبل ذلك شكك الرئيس الروسي بلازم يفوتن في
كفاءاتي بطاريته التي تعتزم واشنطن ارسلها
الى اوكرانيا مقارنه بمنظومات اس 300
الروسيه قائلا من موسكو تمتلك الوسائل
لتدمير الباتشيات
ولا تعمل كما تعمل انظمه اس 300 مثلا ومع
ذلك من يجابه هنا ينطلق من ان هذا السلاح
دفاعي سنخذ هذا في الحسبان ببساطه وسنجد
له ترياقا ومن يفعل ذلك يبطل ابدا لزاعي
فقط سنحطم منظومه باتريات وسيحتاج الغرب
الى جلب اسلحه اخرى
اليه طورنا اسلحه الجيش الروسي للدفاع
وليس الهجوم سنزيد من قدراتنا العسكريه
باضافه اسلحه متطوره مع بدايه السنه روسيا
تثق في تحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا ولا
مجال للتراجع
مع اختتام زياره رئيس الاوكراني الى
الولايات المتحده اكد الكرام لان واشنطن
تخوض حرب بالوكاله ضد روسيا في اوكرانيا
للولايات المتحده يصفها داعيم بالتاريخيه
وتصفها موسكو بتصعيد الواضح
[موسيقى]
العسكريه
2023 الى ان الكريم
الجديده الى اوكرانيا
بالمواجهه العسكريه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
زياره بعد ايام من زياره الروسيه اقلقت
كيف والغرب حاطه فيها بوتين رحاله في بلا
روسيا وارسل من خلالها رسائل واتفاقات عده
ترسم ملامح الجبهه الشرقيه اخترت بلا
روسيا
بالرد العسكري واستعدادها للحرب ضد اي
تهديد الجديده
[موسيقى]
قرابه وعشره اشهر منذ بدا الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا بدا الطرفان بتحسين
القدراتهم العسكريه شيئا فشيئا وابقى
تطلبه تغيرات ارض المعركه روسيا زادت من
قدراتها العسكريه
والصواريخ بعيده المدى
[موسيقى]
ننتقل الان الى افغانستان حيث طردت حركه
طالبان الفتيات من المعاهد النسائيه
والمكتبات التي اغلقوها كجزء من قرار
الحركه الجديد بمنع النساء من اكمال
التعليم الجامعي
افريقيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وقد توعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ستدفع ثمن باهضا بسبب قرارها الاخير بمنع
النساء من التعليم في الجامعه
الدولي لن تتحقق في ظل الاستمرارها في
انتهاك حقوق النساء
واستطيع ان اخبركم انا محاوله طالبان
البحث عن اعتراف دولي وهو ما تريده لن
يحدث اذا استمروا في مثل هذه الاجراءات
بدوره هي اصدر على ازهر الشريف بيانا اعلن
من خلاله انه ياسف بشده لقرار حالك حركه
طالبان بمنع الفتيات من تلق تعليم الجامعي
في افغانستان ونقل الازهر في بيانه
الثلاثه العربيه والانجليزيه والافغانيه
عن شيخ الازهر قوله ان القرار يتناقضوا مع
الشريعه الاسلاميه
ويصدم دعوتها الصريحه للرجال والنساء بان
يطلبوا العلم من المهدي الى اللحد وداع
الازهر اولى اولي الامر في افغانستان الى
مراجعه انفسهم بشان القرار لافتا الى انه
يحذر المسلمين وغير المسلمين من الاعتقاد
بان القول بتحريم تعليم النساء والفتيات
امر يقره الاسلام
وقف المواقف الدوليه ايضا ادانا وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه السبع بشده قرار منع
الفتيات من التعليم في افغانستان معتبرين
اضطيها هذا الفتيات يرقى الى جريمه ضد
الانسانيه
وبيدها لا بيد غيرها كرتون تلو الاخر
لانهاء عزلتها الدوليه
فالحركه التي ظهرت والى التسعيليات من
القرن الماضي الى ان برز نجمها في
افغانستان خليفه عام
1994 الى الان تعيد دوران عقارب الساعه
عكس اتجاهها
حكم الطالبان افغانستان للمره الاولى في
الفتره من
1996 وحتى العام 2001 ووعدت حينها باحلال
السلام والامن والاحترام حقوق الانسان
بمجرد وصولها للسلطه ذلك ما لم يتحقق حضر
الطالبان مشاهده التلفزيون والاستماع الى
الموسيقى وارتياد الدور السينما ورفضت
الذهاب الفتيات من سن العاشره الى المدارس
ودخلت الحركه في عزله دوليه كبيره تمت
الاطاحه حينها بطالبان ولاحقتها مرتكاب
انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
ودخلت في حرب الواسعه النطاق ثم لا حسوا
الحركه مجددا خلال سنوات القليله الماضيه
في افغانستان حيث توفرت فرصه اخرى في ظل
محاوله الغرب دعمها وخلق مساحه للمفاوضات
عادت الحركه الجديده عقبا سحاب القوات
الامريكيه من البلاد العام الماضي
وبسطت سيطرتها بالكامل وفي خضم اعاده الدم
الحركه كان الحديث في ذلك الوقت المطالبه
بتقديم المساعده من المجتمع الدولي وفق
تعهدات للمجتمع الافغاني والعالمي وهي
تعهدات لم تحقق منها الحركه شيئا ومنها ما
تم مؤخرا من حظر الدراسه الجامعيه على
الفتيات
هو كان التاريخ يعيد نفسه من جديد اضاع
الطالبان فرصه من يدها وقطعت شوط اخر
للوراء عصام عبد السلام العربيه
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
في المغرب السلطات تعلن السيطره على حريق
كبير في منشاه غاز بمدينه المحمديه
اهلا بكم من جديد قال قائد القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه الجنرال مايكروريلا ان
الطائرات المسيره الايرانيه
وانها تقوم بانتاج طائره مسيره كبيره
الحجم تطير لمسافات الاطفال وقادر على
حملي كميه اكبر من المتفجرات واضاف
كورالله ان ايران تواصل تقويض الامن
والاستقرار الاقليميين من خلال الميليشيات
والصواريخ البالستيه والطائرات المسيره
وتهديدها المستمر للممرات المائيه الدوليه
مشيرا بحسب صحيفه جروس
والحظر ونشر الاسلحه للشبكتها من الوكلاء
والشركاء او الشركات التابعه لها
والاستلاء على شحنه السفن في المياه
الدوليه قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
كدنا ايران تواصل ونشر الفوضى من خلال
الذين يهاجمون القوه الامريكيه وشركاه
واشنطن في العراق وسوريا واشار كورولا الى
ان النظام الايراني اوله ويدعم الارهاب
والمنظمات الارهابيه ويتحدى الاعراف
الدوليه من خلال القيام بانشطه مزعزعه
للاستقرار
اكدت وزاره الدفاع الفرنسيه تماسكها
بتعزيز الشراكه تاريخيه مع السعوديه واقله
الوزراء ان الوزيره دفاع الفرنسي
سيباستيانو
اتفق مع نظيره السعودي الامير خالد بن
سلمان على تعزيز الحوار بينهما في مواجهه
تحديدات في منطقه الشرق الاوسط واوروبا
اشتدت صراعته بين كيانات ومجال الشرق
السودان اذ عقدت عددا من التنظيمات بالفعل
عقدت مؤتمرات صحفيه لتوضيح موقفها من
الراهن السياسي وقد برزت الخلافات حول
نقطه المؤيدين للاتفاق الايطالي
والمعارضين له
هنا الشرق مكان لا يهدا يشتعل سياسيا يوما
بعد اخر هنا خير مثال لما يمر به السودان
من تشد وانشقاق
بمكونات الشرق ومجالسها وقبائليها فتعددت
المسميات والتحالفات وتشتت المواقف هنا
التهديد والوعيد بان الانفصال خيار حاضر
ان لم تتم الاستجابه للمطالب
انهم هم
حاجات السودان
يستوردها عبر الموانئ ما في مشكله مقابل
ذلك
اقل من 24 ساعه لتنظيمات وكيانات من شرق
السودان يعلنون فيها موقفهم من الرهن
السياسي اللافت ان المجلس الاعلى لنظارات
البيجا والمواقعين على اتفاقيه جوبا كانوا
حتى وقت قريب هم من يعبرون عن مواطن الشرق
السودان قبل ان ينقسم جميعهم ويتناثر الى
مجموعه عديده حزب المؤتمر البيئه
في العام 94,900
والذي استمر 14 عام
نطالب
ونتمسك بتنفيذ الكامل لهذا الاتفاق
القديمه والجديده وكذلك الادارات الاهليه
والموقعين على اتفاق جوبا وضح الصراع بين
المؤيدين للاتفاق الايطالي والمعارضين له
وبارزت مفارقه جديده انه لا خلاف بينهم في
الاهداف والمقاصد المتمثله بتنفيذ مخرجات
مؤتمر
الذي يتحدث باسم اهل الشرق
نحن لا نلتفت الى الاصوات العاليه
والتي نعتبرها الان لا تعبر
انها ايضا تعبر عن الصوت مجموعه معينه
خلال هذا الشهر برزت مجموعه برئاسه شيب
ضرار اعلنت حمل السلاح في وجه السلطه
واغلقت الميناء لمده يوم كما برز تقارب
بين مكونات من الشرق مع تحالفات العسكريه
وسياسيه متعدده وهو ما يشير الى ان قضيه
الشرق باتت من اكثر القضايا المعقده التي
تواجهها الفتره الانتقاليه لينا يعقوب
العربيه الخرطوم
اعلنت السلطات المغربيه
قرب الدار البيضاء من دون ان يسخر عن وقوع
اصابته
على خمسه صهاريج سعه كل منها ثمانيه
ارتفع عدد المهاجرين الى الولايات المتحده
عام 2022 بعد خمس سنوات من التراجع مسجلا
اكبر زياده منذ اكثر من عقد مع اعاده فتح
الحدود في نهايه 2021 بعد اغلاقها بسبب
كورونا وبحسب تقديرات الصادر عن مكتب
الاحصاء الوطنيه
اضاف اكثر من مليون شخص الى سكان الولايات
المتحده بين الاول من يوليو 2021 والاول
من يوليو 2022
بعد اربع سنوات من وصولها الى سطح الكوكب
الاحمر على نتيجه الطيران والفضاء
الامريكيه ناصر رسميا تقاعد مركبه الفضاء
الموجوده بالمريخ ان سعيد وهي اول مسبار
اريس صمم خصيصا لدراسه الاجزاء الداخليه
العميقه لعالم بعيد
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
لجنه التحقيق في احداث الكافتون
مؤامره لقلبي نتيجه انتخابات الرئاسه
وروسيا تدعو الولايات المتحده الى الاسراء
بصوت العقل وتجنب صدام المباشر بين
البلدين
والازهار يدعو طالبان لمراجعه قرار حرمان
الفتيات من التعليم قبل امكانيه توعد
الحركه بدفع ثمن
حسن متابعه مشاهدينا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]